شاهد هذه الصور التي تاتينا من محيط
العاصمه الخرطوم حيث تصاعد لاعمده الدخان
في اشاره الى على ما يبدو استمرار
المواجهات انها طرفي الصراع على الرغم من
توقيع هدنه تتعلق بضروره فتح ممرات
انسانيه وهي الجهود التي بذلتها المملكه
العربيه السعوديه خلال الايام الماضيه
وترجمت في اعلان جدا لاقامه هدنه حتى يتم
السماح بدخول المساعدات الانسانيه عبر
ممرات انسانيه ولكن الصور المباشره التي
تاتينا الان من العاصمه الخرطوم تشير الى
هذا التصاعد في اعمده الدخان في اشاره على
استمرار الوضع الامني غير المستقر
هذه المشاهد تاتي من محيط العاصمه الخرطوم
ربما من محيط القياده العامه السودانيه
والتي كثيرا ما كانت تشهد هذه المواجهات
بين طرفي الصراع قوات الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع كانت هناك جهود دوليه
كثيره بذلت خلال الايام الماضيه للتوصل
الى هدنه حقيقيه الا ان الاقتتال على
الارض لم يتوقف حتى اللحظه البيت الابيض
كان اعلن منذ قليل انه يواصل الاتصالات مع
الشركاء والحلفاء في المنطقه وذلك من اجل
توفير اليه يتم بها مراقبه وقف اطلاق
النار
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات